Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This'll be my Ahsoka Episode 2 video
There are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references.
Lots more callbacks and things
where Knights of the Old Republic
in some of the games.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes we're doing that
give away for the Echo dot.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber,
a post your favorite Easter egg
from the episode on the video.
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on Ahsoka through episode
one in episode
two would start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode
titled Toil in Trouble, Which sounds like
another reference to Morgan Elsbeth
being a knight's sister, like a force
which all about her Eye of Zion,
that she's building her giant hyper
gait ring device that she's going to use
to bring Thrawn back to this galaxy.
There are a couple of interesting things
that they do with the legends canon too.
Like were they sort of clarified that he's
now in a completely alternate galaxy,
not just in the unknown regions,
the actual opening scene
is just the aftermath of Sabine's
fight, getting her ass handed to her by
shin hati getting run through
with the lightsaber
recovering in a hospital.
Ahsoka watching over her hearing Ezra's
voice again,
Then we get a bunch more references to
Knights of the Old Republic in the night.
Sisters Baylan Skoll calls
This place here
a reflex point is a point of departure
that Ahsoka just asked Sabine about,
and it's all about
finding a safe hyperspace route
through the unknown regions
to this other galaxy
that Morgan Elspeth is talking about.
the whole idea is that there is no known
hyperspace routes between galaxies,
so you'd be completely flying blind,
like you could fly into something
through something. You die instantly.
When Morgan Elsbeth
says the people who built this waypoint
structure in the star map were ancient
and from that distant galaxy,
she's talking about the record,
an infinite empire.
maybe.
Dave Filoni is also borrowing
some Easter eggs for the koi race.
They built the infinity gates.
They also existed around that same time
period, like more than 25,000 years ago.
all these different races
had either hyper gates or ways
to travel around galaxies instantaneously
but in the Star Wars
canon, there are a number of races
that were from outside the galaxy.
Most people think of the use of Vong.
but they're relatively more recent rays.
Most of the races that we're talking about
are like really ancient,
long dead species.
so what they might be doing
is just bending the canon
a little bit and saying the broken
and also came from a different galaxy,
not just inside the main galaxy,
because at least in the Knights
of the Old Republic,
they were supposed to have come
from the main galaxy
where all the regular Star Wars
characters in present day come from.
Notice Morgan Elsbeth using her Knights
sister abilities, confirming that she is
force sensitive like she has for Knights
sister to activate the star map.
That's what the green flame energy is.
It looks just like
it did during Clone Wars.
zoom in.
Enhance on some of the symbols on the star
map here as it's moving around.
You see the space wells
depicted here in the energy, the Purrgils
implying that the ricotta or whoever
this race was that created
this were able to harness
the same abilities
the Persians have to navigate
through hyperspace in a more superior way
than standard hyperdrive computers.
Baylan refers to this other
galaxy is parity Saying that it was told
to Jedi younglings at the old temple On
course on is a fairy tale.
But Morgan Elsbeth reveals that part of
that fairy tale was based on truth.
Notice when she closes her eyes too.
She isn't having a good time there.
She's just listening to the voices of
other dead nine sisters through the force
and supposedly listening to Throne's
voice across space, time, space and time.
Mind you,
That's
one of the unique abilities of Knights
sisters
raising the dead forms of necromancy.
Speaking to the dead
regular Jedi can become force spirits
and then speak to the living.
Whoever they want.
Like you don't have to be a Jedi
to speak to a force spirit.
use that to be specially trained
as a Jedi.
Like very powerful in the force
to actually become a force.
Retain your consciousness, your sense of
self after you become one with the force.
When everybody does, when they die,
normally in the Star Wars universe,
when a character dies,
their body just turns into pure energy,
into force,
like you essentially go back to the force.
But powerful Jedi who can become force
bears, are able
to retain their sense of self.
That's basically what a force ghost is.
one of the reasons why Anakin Skywalker
was able to become a force goes
even though he didn't receive training,
it was because he was so powerful
in the force.
literally, he's
meant to be a child of the mid-air
chlorians like a child of the force.
the special green energy here
they call magic.
It's the nine Sisters
unique way of using the force,
accessing or communing with the force.
It's a special kind of force energy.
They just tap into and manipulate
normal Jedi.
I insist. Can't do that. The crazy.
Our ability here, though,
and this is a nice sister ability,
is that she can communicate
across galaxies like she can communicate
to this other galaxy where throne is.
I'm listening to him,
also listening to him across time.
feels like they're trying to show you
how powerful she really is
just to hype up
another rematch fight with Ahsoka.
Later in the series.
The interesting thing
here, though, is how excited Baylan Skoll
sounds when he talks about
Theron's return in the chaos Little brain
like he's excited for the war
against the New Republic
in this new empire to form under Thrawn,
That's
why for some it means a new beginning.
But for them, those two, it means immense
power what he might be referring to.
Is it a Thrawn ruled
Galaxy will just offer him complete access
to anything and everything he needs to
make himself more powerful in the force.
Like holograms, weapons,
artifacts, special temples that help him
harness force energy.
Maybe he intends on creating a new school
in the force for this dark Jedi practice.
Like, whatever it is,
he practices in the force,
basically do whatever he wants to do.
when Ahsoka goes back to being Ren's home,
you notice
she uses the force
to sense the events of their fight,
sort of like a Jedi instant replay,
and she tricks the last remaining
HK droid in takes his memory core
so they able to find out about Morgan
Elspeth operation on Chiarelli
that is still active For the most part.
Chiarelli in pretty much every Star Wars
story has been used for their shipyards
in some way.
They built ships for the old Republic
during that era, the republic after them,
then the empire after them,
and now the New Republic.
mostly, though, it's all about making
money, which they play up in the episode.
Like you have
the leader of the shipyards here basically
serving his quote unquote, investors
being just as evil as the empire.
pretty much most of the people on
Chiarelli are kind of like that.
loyalties mostly to the dollar, not to
the New Republic or to the empire itself.
Like they don't really care too much
about the government, just about money.
Han Solo is from Karelia,
but he doesn't like going back there,
mostly because of his troubled
upbringing. There.
this small ship is
The Phantom, is from Star Wars rebels.
It was used by the crew of the ghost
when they needed a smaller craft.
Min Weaver
here is not a character from the canon.
He's just another new character
they introduced for this storyline.
He has an R.A. seven Droid.
they just featured one
during The Mandalorian recently.
And most people remember them as the Death
Star droid, which is kind of apropos
because he winds up being a secret plan
for Morgan
Elsbeth, like secretly he's serving her
just because she's paying so well.
a lot of people also remember R.A.
seven from the Jar and Crawler
to They remind you that Hera is still
an active general in the New Republic,
like she's still on duty.
So she technically does wield
a lot of political power and authority.
pretty much every member of the crew.
The ghost became part of the rebellion
in some way.
They revealed that Morgan Ellsberg's
actual job under Thrawn in the Empire
was building these giant hyper drives for
full size in pure class star destroyers.
And now she's using it
to build the giant one for her hyper gate.
most people probably figured out
the direction this was headed
when they started talking about the people
working there, still being mostly empire
at every level of the government.
There's former Imperials.
more examples of how poorly
the New Republic has been managing
the transition from the Empire
to their new system of government.
There's so many pissed off former
Imperials working in the New Republic.
It's a wonder that they haven't overthrown
the New Republic without Thrawn help
or without the need of Thrones help.
and he's not wrong when he talks
about the actual rank and file workers.
Like most people here, don't
actually care who's in charge
as long as they get paid on time.
They actually got into this phenomenon
on House of the Dragon,
like in the Game of Thrones universe
where the peasants
didn't really care about the inner
workings of the Targaryen family
or any particular civil war
that they might be having or inviting.
they were mostly worried
about where they were going
to get food and water from each day
just surviving to the next day.
here are trying to talk Ahsoka
into making nice with Sabine
and them getting the family back together,
so to speak.
Is kind of her being the space
mom of the ghost crew.
That was kind of the vibe of her character
during Star Wars
Rebels kind of being everyone's mom
Speaking of which, a lot of people
asking about her son with Kanan Jason.
He was in the trailers.
We haven't seen them yet.
So probably one of the future
episodes really important to remember
that he is also for sensitive.
Maybe at some point
Ahsoka will also train him back on lethal.
When Hu Yang starts talking about Ezra
Bridgers lightsaber now being Sabine's
technically because he gave it to her
and she's modified it.
It's just the idea.
I think that
when Ezra does eventually come back,
she's not going to hand it back to him
like, Oh, I kept this safe for you.
It will just continue
being her light saber.
lot of people wondering
what's going on with Ezra Bridger.
Like, is he really in this other galaxy
or is he secretly going to wind up
being the inquisitor Marrok character
Either way, when he comes back,
he'll either have constructed
a new lightsaber himself or
he'll just be using some other lightsaber.
really interesting
to find out what he did all those years
while he was supposedly stuck
in this other galaxy with Thrawn.
his all comment about moving forward,
letting the past go
is also meant to be a reference
to Ahsoka, his past trauma
with the Skywalker Order 66, Darth Vader,
everything that came after it,
never having really dealt with it
in until she does, she's going to continue
having problems like this with everyone
like Sabine says, Oh, Ahsoka left me.
She just took off at some point.
that's probably
because she's afraid to get close
to people because of what happened with.
And again, they'll probably be at least
a couple more Anakin
Skywalker references before
we get or actual Anakin Skywalker.
Hayden Christensen Cameo.
The Imperial loyalists inside
the hyperdrive business reveal themselves
and we finally get our chase scene
in the soldiers
standoff with the Marrok Inquisitor
or former Inquisitor character
Here it goes after the hyperdrive
and the Phantom with choppers.
Help is Chopper's
first appearance on the series.
His personality has not changed at all
since Rebels.
He's as sassy as ever.
Did you mess with my stuff?
No, I didn't mess with your stuff.
bazookas
fight with Merak is pretty decent.
It kind of shows off
some of his skills as an inquisitor,
although we still kind of wondering
who's underneath that mask.
He barely escapes.
A soldier does get him dead to rights,
but he's saved by Shane Harty,
Sounds like that
A rematch will probably happen in episode
three hear him manage to get that
tracking device on the transport.
But they'll probably be unable
to stop them
ultimately from using that hyper gate
to bring Thrawn back.
Like that's the whole idea
is that you want the war between Thrawn
in the New Republic that Dave Filoni
has been hyping up for a couple of years
now, One of the terms we use is,
you know, the war between the New Republic
and the Remnant empire.
So we're going to see, you know,
you need a conflict.
And I'm, you know, just kind of looking
at a lot of the things that were written
over the years in various
expanding universe projects, trying
not just to look at what John and I did,
but we're looking at what was done
kind of historically in the time
period is a guide,
there is a treasure of things to
to draw from,
not just within our own series,
but in the bigger galaxy.
the whole idea is that the Ahsoka series
is meant to end the finale with him
returning to the galaxy with his fleet,
either the seventh fleet of ships
or like a new fleet of ships
that he found in this other galaxy.
Then they'll begin either
the Mandalorian Season four
or the Thrawn movie with the actual war
against the New Republic beginning
kind of like the beginning
of Revenge of the Sith,
where they start in that space battle.
Like you open up and it's immediately
in the middle of the battle
while this is all
happening, Sabine reassembles
her Mandalorian armor pieces.
This is a symbol for the rebellion.
I think this other poll run is actually
for the space wells like the Pergolas.
She actually has a symbol of approval
to represent her quest to find
Ezra Bridger again in his connection
with the pergola at the end of rebels.
and she cuts her hair
to the same short link
that was at the end of rebels
in that ending scene
So essentially it's the same ending scene
from rebels like the same animated scene,
but in live action
with a few minor changes.
But essentially it's the exact same scene.
When she cuts her hair.
That's exactly same thing that Kanan did.
So it's like that George Lucas quote,
it's like poetry.
It rhymes Maybe if we're lucky, we'll
get a Kanan flashback with live action.
Freddie Prinze playing the character.
Or maybe like a force goes. Kanan Seen.
now we've completely caught up
with the end of Star Wars rebels.
so essentially Episode
three is the beginning of what you would
call Star Wars rebels Season five.
they reveal the eye of Cyan
is being finished near that Cetus planet.
We were just that in the day
nap system in the outer rim.
The planet has not been featured
before in Star Wars like it's brand new,
but the system has been featured
in various stories.
notice that Ahsoka also calls
Sabine Wren her Padawan.
Again, as I say, she's fully
accepted her back as her master
and they'll resume her
Jedi training in episode three.
when you look at the I assign here to
at the end of the episode.
Really great way to end the episode.
It seems similar to the smaller
hyperdrive rings
that the characters
use during the prequels.
The reason they need one
this big though, is
because they'll be jumping an entire fleet
through hyperspace.
So the rain needs to extend
around the entire fleet.
basically make a giant hyperspace bubble.
They can take a bunch of stuff
through the whole thing here
with Baylan Skoll
being sad about having to kill Ahsoka
is just hyping up their fight, which will
probably happen in episode three
They want to show that
he doesn't have a problem killing Ahsoka,
but he is sad to see the Jedi
slowly die out even more,
I think given enough time he'd
rather try and turn her or bend her
to his way of thinking like this new path
that he wants to pursue, that
the force or other force
sensitives that he might come upon.
Like the whole idea that under Thrawn
he'll develop his own Jedi Academy
that will just pursue their own way
through the force,
not necessarily
full light side or dark side.
More like that
then do kind of both sides of the force,
maybe even a darker path,
because we do have orange light sabers
now everybody's wondering what
this is going to mean for Luke Skywalker.
Like obviously he's
going to have something to say about this.
Do The couple more cool references
to Knights of the Old Republic
and a lot of the legends
canon re canonizing stuff.
So there anything in the episode
that you spotted that
I didn't mention in the video
just right up below in the comments
but just expect
more of this in future episodes
those will probably clarify
exactly who this race was
from the other galaxy
in the next couple of episodes.
my episode three trailer video we'll post
in the next day or two in my full
episode three video we'll post next week
after they release it.
Click here for my Ahsoka
Episode one video and click here for that
brand new House of the Dragon Season
2 Teaser Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!